e aí galera que assistiu ao canal do
banco vocês alisa o cabelo agora estou
parecendo uma sobrinha minha hora foi
indicada em cinco categorias do mtv me
auxiliasse fala miau miau miau eu e
minha mãe chica pegorer como é fato a
votarem do jeito ou pelo site entrou no
site pode votar quantas vezes quiser
pode ficar voltava votava o 1 você pode
dar rt neste tweet aqui o que que é o
primeiro link na descrição do vídeo no
twitter da drt é um voto gente cada rt
instituit é um vôo cada vez que você usa
duas hashtag é um valor concreto e
colocou a hashtag um voto gente dá rt
bola dessas por tudo a ganhar assim
categoria na saída com as comissões de
cor branca aparece no avião seguiam c
o byonce avaliou co para complicar eu
falo não é deus e fala não haviam se que
[ __ ] merda seria tão difícil falar o
nome das ruas ninguém sabe como é que se
pronuncia como é que se tire uns eu acho
muito pobre mas remédio é feito três
horas 20 miligramas de beyoncé é igual
ao lado de carlinhos sabiá pablo ou é o
pablo é o pago para evitar ou pago a
vitor eu não sei o que eu pergunto pra
mim como é que eu chamo em sanaa pablo
ou é o pablo nenhum dos dois faz o
senhor é k é assim que o show na verdade
eu acho que independente do jeito como
você chama absorvem é isso assunto sei
que enquanto falam 'você não sabe você
está falando que você ouve pode impactar
10 sem placa nvi um destes em troca
aproveitar aquele que gostei aí que eu
sei que vai esquecer no final do vídeo
então já que fica logo se esquecerá
clique em inscrever se a idade que eu ia
falar que eu sou um cara que assisti
muito filmes vem no canal de que a
assistir a um filme adaptar porque eu
adoro filme eu assisti muito filme só
que tem uma coisa em filme que eu não
consigo compreender vai além da minha
compreensão mas é porque as pessoas
demoram a concluir o objetivo delas no
filme o vilão do filme sempre quer
contar o plano antes que acontecerá a
acontecer acho que esse dia nunca
chegaria não é mesmo estiver enfim
chegou
chegou a hora de fazer com o mundo tudo
aquilo que eu sempre foi aaa a aa eu
irei de destruir esta terra' a assentar
um capanga que questiona mais mestres e
destruímos a terra
temos embora eu governe somente a a
encontrar falar no plano para destruir a
terra pessoa que está amarrada consegue
bolar um plano ou chamar reforço e então
eu olhei você foi mais esperto que desta
vez de silva mas não será assim na
próxima vez a otabol queria saber porque
é que as pessoas em filmes são tão
dramática a bruxa tá fazendo a porção
uma banana um fio de cabelo daquela que
consumará ela corta um tufo de cabelo
desta brochura uma gota de sangue da
terceira filha de 17 o pai de hugo de
sangue uma gota de sangue o que ela faz
o que ela vai se romper do dia um corta
o tamanho do mundo era só a gota de
sangue e fazer o exame de diabetes
morava aqui pronto isso não faz assim ó
a adoção é submetida estande sangue só
uma porção é a galinha o papo outra
cópia do tempo que a vítima sempre corre
o vilão sempre devagar isso quando não
tá bancando o vilão sempre aparece na
frente de casa correndo
penso que não há como saber isso
aconteceu pelo be o motoboy que eu fico
pensando que ninguém sente fome não vem
ninguém comenta o filme acontece passar
dia passa a noite vira noite vira dia
não vejo ninguém confunda também é [ __ ]
[Música]
dodô não quer que o estado daquele eles
acham que aqui é rio xingu é e querem o
quê atingir nos assustar os [ __ ] e 6º
ano isso é realmente maravilhoso e
tutinha da dublagem deixa o inglês -
legendado cartão sim é moda porque é
fábio caiu a tentadora que era a cena de
um velho tá brigando com e amanda focar
isso dá um toque o cara falou que
decolavam em oito voltas sendo a ver
como é dublado cara vá se dá na cara já
portas à cidadana respeito que nasceu
para ser vacinado conhecer vai tomar no
cu que a gente agressiva ou fazer o
seguinte daqui pra frente do vídeo toda
vez que eu vou xingar eu vou botar como
espécie dublado em português não consigo
entender é igual ao filme musical música
quanto eu não te odeia acho que você
sabe do cérebro adulto você não aguenta
a partir da música no filme música tá
gostando do frio começa a música faz o
que você está assistindo nascendo é
estilo o que acha de irmos ao refeitório
e poderia ir agora mesmo quer ver se
pensar quando vamos a um refeitório mas
só parte da música eu fiquei mesmo
aborrecido é mais botar defeito do filme
que esse cara sabe a letra c não sabem a
música que eu queria cantar aí do nada
raça é a letra aí do nada um
levantamento dos skatistas começa a
dançar e os skatistas dançando nem
conhece o cara do filme dançando a
música que está tocando caramba
bola é do grupo dos nerds
aí eu sabe meu de macacos me mordam
fiquei mesmo aborrecido agora um nerd
saber dançar break breaks não sabe dança
nem capoeira aí começa a guerra de
comida eu fico indignado o povo não se
preocupa em guerra de comida chega o
diretor sem um pingo de moral o diretor
parei com isso entra na brincadeira as
comidas voamos no torta de amora se uma
caixinha de suco ou sanduíche de atuam
na minha escola se tivesse computar ia
nas aulas
chegava a professora galeno reprovável
medo era professora professora contar
para a mãe que é professora ea mãe
escola pública olha ai amiga guerra de
comida me como é quem joga essas comida
como a feira publica macarrão com
salsicha do extreme crack com doce de
goiaba
os cursos com ong é isso eo tango show
cês são os shows que tem outros três e
da pausa e se você quiser ver graça no
meu site não esquece clicar em gostei
aqui o vídeo é muito importante e ajuda
na votação vale o primeiro longa
descrição do vídeo e da rtp que cada r
tem um voto e cada vez que você tuíta
com aquelas duas tags é um voto também
não faz isso ajuda se escreve o canal
quando eu perder um vídeo novo tamo
junto é nós e aguarde mais vídeos aí com
o cabelo assim